HONEST TRAILER : PARANORMAL ACTIVITY
NARRATOR
In 2009, a screening was held.
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
This audience was the first to experience
a new horror phenomenon.
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
What they saw... left them...
BORED.
REALLY, REALLY BORED.
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
Paranormal Activity.
Get ready to experience the cheaper, less
interesting version
of The Blair Witch Project.
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
Behold the terror of a film so easy, anyone’s
dad could have shot it.
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
And so cheap, it’s created a genre of handheld
crap.
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
Prepare to be terrified...
By a marketing department so effective, they
actually made cities demand this tedious home
movie...
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
that substitutes shaky camerawork for legitimate
horror.
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
With a premise that they’ll milk for at
least five more movies.
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
A movie for an audience so gullible...
they think that a moving sheet is scary.
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
Featuring a guy that can’t stop acting like
a total douchebag…
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
Who plans to fight an invisible demon by yelling
at it.
MICAH:
“Show yourself!”
NARRATOR:
And a less hot Katy Perry, who basically just
cries a lot.
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
Together, they will confront the terrifying
question of why he’s filming so much.
KATIE:
“Put the camera away.
KATIE (CONT’D)
You and your stupid camera are the problem.”
“Maybe we shouldn’t have the camera.
You have to turn off the camera.
Will you stop following me with the camera!”
NARRATOR:
A shocking tale where characters point out
what’s scary,
MICAH:
“Door is freaking moving by itself.”
NARRATOR:
Walk through an empty house, and sleep.
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
For, like, 60 percent of the movie.
With a mystery so deep, you’ll be constantly
asking...
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
is she hot or is it just her big boobs?
Brace yourself for 86 minutes of…
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
a Guitar.
A door.
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
A Fridge.
Some Empty Rooms A ceiling grate.
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
A chandelier.
Some Blinds.
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
An attic door.
Stairs, stairs, stairs, stairs…
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
Juliet from Lost?
and stairs.
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
Starring...
No one.
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
Paranormal activity.
I guess I’ll go see it this Halloween.
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
Nothing else is playing.
Maybe we should friend each other on facebook.
NARRATOR (CONT’D)
The link’s in the doobly-doo.
As per the uje, leave a comment telling us
what movie you’d like to see getting the
honest treatment next and leave a quote you’d
like to hear me say next time in my epic trailer
voice.